[Música]
desde muy pequeño yo me di cuenta que yo
era muy diferente
raro si lo quieren llamar veía el mundo
muy distinto como que no encajaba y no
tenía el más mínimo interés de encajar
al revés
quería sobresalir quería como enaltecer
mi rareza
a los pobres de mis zapatos y sufrir
muchísimo porque yo quería ropa distinta
comida distinta decoración y todo todo
yo quería que fuera diferente
crecí en una sociedad
mexicana muy machista en una iglesia
llena de amor pero muy conservadora
-este mis ideas siempre me están
metiendo en problemas siempre causaba
mucha controversia y en la escuela la
verdad es que las escuelas siento yo que
no están diseñadas para para gente como
yo desde que empecé la escuela me
diagnosticaron heidi y era muy difícil
para mí concentrarme la verdad es que me
iba muy mal en la escuela reprobados
migratorias era lindo los maestros me
amaban pero me costaba mucho mucho
trabajo concentrarme me la vivía esté
dibujando distrayendo a los demás
estudiantes
y yo de verdad creía de todo corazón
quien no me servía nada de lo que no
está que no me iba a servir nada de lo
que me estaba enseñando porque yo tenía
muy claro que yo iba a trabajar en otra
realidad yo quería un mundo de moda de
glamour y entonces decía todo lo que me
está enseñando no me está sirviendo a
nada entonces obviamente fue difícil
para mí la escuela a los pobres de mis
papás y los hicieron sufrir mucho de
mandarlo a esta terapia esta terapia
esta terapia fui a un sinfín de terapias
según yo no ayudaron mucho este y tomate
este medicamento tu hijo es especial y
especial es raro en otro este y a mí la
verdad es que no me afectaba no solo no
me afectaba como que me daba
como energía para yo yo sabía que yo
quería una realidad distinta a la que yo
había en la que yo había nacido no yo
quería crear una realidad nueva y no
entendía por qué tenía que ir a una
escuela normal con niños normales yo
quería algo distinto no entonces cuando
recibía estos comentarios que más bien
eran las a mis papás más pero de tu hijo
es muy especial tiene que ir a estas
terapias te la verdad es que desde muy
chico decidí que yo no iba a dejar que
la percepción de los demás lo que los
demás opinaban de mí
afectará lo que yo sabía que yo tenía
adentro no y lo que yo era y mis papás
me enseñaron desde muy chico que dios me
había creado con un propósito y que él
tenía un plan para mi vida y yo me tomé
de esa enseñanza y me la creía al 100%
continuaron los años tengo dos hermanas
mayores que tenían muchas revistas de
moda y marco que me devoraba sus
revistas y me enamoré de las de las
papas los de los 90s este de gianni
versace
de este mundo donde yo sabía yo tengo
que pertenecer a ese mundo de la moda y
me urge yo contaba los días para salirme
de esta vida subraya normal y yo ya
quería estar en parís en milán o este
marco que le agarraba las barbies está a
mis primas y les cambiaba el look y les
pintaba mechones para el plumón y les
cortaba el pelo y ya se tramaban este a
una pobre amiga le dije te voy a caber
todo tu look este me toca cómo te
arreglas y le cambia su ropa y la
empezar maquillar y hasta agarré un
barniz de uñas yo sin saber y dije esto
es como metálico son increíble y le
pinte los párpados le queme los párpados
acabó en el hospital la pobre niña pues
lava así me metía en muchos problemas
pero era un niño lindo no nomás que era
muy traviesa y tenían mucha imaginación
muchas ideas
este es mi amor por la moda fue
creciendo la que una vez mi abuela me
compró una revista le pedí que comprar
en el super este una revista 'vanity
fair' no porque me encantaba la portada
que había hecho annie leibovitz y cuando
mi papá la vio me dijo qué haces leyendo
esa basura o sea feria de vanidad porque
quieres lees esto y le dije es que no yo
no entendía lo que significaba ese
título no pero era es que quiero quiero
ver este mundo quiero este es el glamour
de este de este mundo no que que me
apasiona y me llama
y yo sabía no como que yo tenía toda esa
convicción de ahí es donde yo voy a
acabar no sé cómo no sé cómo por dónde
me voy a ir metiendo pero sé que ahí voy
a acabar
fueron pasando los años esté en la vez
que tenía muchos amigos muchos amigos
este hombres y mujeres pero me daba
mucha flojera mis amigos hombres porque
solo hablaban de soccer y yo odiaba el
soccer se no sabe a jugarlo y no lo
soportaba aunque marcó que una vez le
robe a mi hermano su el hermano es muy
atleta te robe sus tacos porque me
gustaba caminar por el pasillo en la
escuela e ir haciendo ruido este pero me
acoge de mis amigos querían escuchar
molo todo y este control machete y yo
quería escuchar jeans y caray y spies
collins como que nunca encajaba al 100
pero a mí me a mí me gustaba no encajar
yo quería siguiente yo yo quería
sobresalientes a mí no me no me afectaba
eso a los 12 años después de tanto amor
por la moda les dije a mis papás ya se
lo como estudiar de grande diseño de
moda y se impartan no qué horror es que
ese mundo seguro es puro sexo droga y
rock and roll los a pura banalidad no no
no no no éste y tanto les afecto que me
llevaron a hablar con el pastor de la
iglesia no es un hombre súper
conservador pero la vez que se portó
súper lindo conmigo y estamos platicando
y
mira yo creo que dios diseñó el cielo y
la tierra diseñó al mundo entonces dios
te puede usar en cualquier ámbito en el
donde tú quieras acabar no hay tú puedes
brillar ya mí se quedó muy grabado dios
diseñó entonces dije guau si dios es un
diseñador yo voy a hacer un diseñador
sea punto eso es lo que me quedo de la
plática entonces siguieron los años y
creo que mis papás fueron viendo mi
obsesión por esta pasión que yo tenía
pero mi determinación y que yo quería
trabajar usando queda que me lo
regalaron entonces conforme fueron
pasando esos años cuando llegó el
momento de ir a estudiar eso el apoyo
vino de donde menos lo esperarías de mis
papás me apoyaron en absolutamente todo
fui a la escuela estudio diseño moda y
estudiando diseño este durante la
universidad consiguió un trabajo de
medio tiempo produciendo desfiles de
modas locales y empecé desde abajo salió
le ponía este tape a los zapatos para
que no se ensucia la quitaba etiquetas
planchar la ropa cargada montaba racks
todo todo desde hasta abajo y aprendí
muchísimo y acabando la universidad
decidí que quiera trabajar en una
agencia de modelos en nueva york
unas prácticas profesionales me
escogieron agarra mis maletas y me fui a
nueva york y llegué a esta oficina super
grande en soho super imponente marco
perfecto a los nervios no de llegar y me
recibió la recepcionista
me gusta su preocupando tengo tiempo
para para enseñarte nada ahorita
siéntate aquí no súper presentes y
yo no me importa no sabes cómo cuando
porque ya llegué estaba como observando
observando y ahí vi a un hombre que se
veía muy alto como musculoso grande no
esté italia uno de estos pero como de
teléfono y dije el seguro es importante
y se estaba quejando de que abren las
cajas
estorbando y nadie los que haces como
que los gringos muy haciendo yo no cargo
cajas entonces y que me lo echa la bolsa
y agarré las cajas escuché lo que quería
y las móvil pues llegó este hombre así
enorme nois y me dijo qué haces
estévez nave oficina yo a éste y
llegados y médico porque muestras cajas
le dije pues porque te vi que te estás
quejando de que las cajas y nadie te
hace caso es las que se movió y por ese
detallito de que me ensucie las manos y
de que me puse a cambiar en vez de estar
esperando me promovió desde ese día a
trabajar en la mesa con los agentes
obviamente las resoluciones también
idiomas
y empecé a trabajar con ellos estaba
increíble y yo tenía esta meta de quiero
que todos vean que soy el primero en
llegar a la oficina y el último yo no
tenía llaves ni tenía el password
entonces yo llegara antes para que me
viera la primera persona en llegar que
yo ya estaba sentado así antes este y
vivía lejísimos y medio metro pero no me
importaba amaba lo que hacía ya que
cuando estaban llevando yo empecé en el
verano y luego el invierno llegó estaba
nevando nadie quería salir y decían hay
quien va por comida que yo me ofrecía
siempre porque me compraban la comida yo
quiera ahorrar dinero no me dan mi
comida gratis y va a todos lados la
verdad es que tuve la bendición de que
empecé a
rápidamente me empezaron a mandar este
álbum de oscar de la renta carolina
herrera michael kors los mejores
senadores de nueva york
y me impactó mucho porque conocí gente
muy poderosa a joel a nadie yo estaba
hasta abajo y se portaron tan lindos con
mi vida la gente más poderosa era por lo
general la más linda y la más humilde
marcado y esto fue antes de las redes
sociales
lacko que íbamos yo y mis amigos de
trabajo y todos estábamos backstage en
los desfiles
todo y nos tomamos fotos nada y no
tenemos que presumir sel a nadie
vivíamos el momento y con toda la
entrega yo disfrutaba tanto lo que hacía
y mako muy claro otra cosa que me marcó
muchísimo bueno obviamente todo el día
andaba por la calle con excel y
demarcada mis papás en mis ratos libres
a contarles lo que estaba haciendo a
quien ha reconocido ya que ya había
visto este y un día estaba bucks ella en
un desfile creo que da busca de la renta
y estaba yo esté en los baños de
backstage y al lado de mí estaba una
modelo súper famosa haciendo el baño y
como que me quedé muy marcada ese día de
uaw todos hacemos del baño igual o sea
como que todos somos iguales este y
estando en nueva york trabajé con
modelos rusas eslovacas base todo menos
mexicanas no me tocó una mexicana en ese
tiempo empecé a decir a mis jefes son a
la gente que sabe más que yo porque no
hay modelos mexicanas porque no llegan
las mexicanas y llegan niñas de todos
países y menciona a las mexicanas son
súper flojas este no se separan de su
novio no dejan a la familia no viaja no
sean las mexicanas no son buenas modelos
y yo sabía que había
dos modelos mexicanas que han llegado a
la cima en su momento es elsa benítez y
wílliam amigas y o sea tiene que haber
más mexicanas yo las quiero encontrar y
se metió mucho en la cabeza de voy a
regresarme a mexico a abrir una agencia
de modelos y encontrar talentos de
modelos mexicanas y mandar la sala a las
mejores ciudades de molano y pero fue
difícil porque tenía un trabajo
increíble nueva york
de las mejores agencias del mundo estaba
yo muy chico dije cómo lo va a hacer
cómo hacer que me peleé las agencias
como posada fue difícil no dejar eso
pero
me ganó la pasión me atreví me vine a
méxico le dije a mi agencia que nombre y
se me ocurrió zombi malos porque quería
un nombre cortito que significaba lo
mismo en inglés español y una amiga me
dijo a la vida está horrible tu nombre
es cero profesional dame unas horas con
un diccionario y yo todo encontrar un
nombre mi amiga mariana y ella le puso
el nombre para mí me encantó este y abrí
la agencia y la agencia era mi laptop mi
nextel en la azotea de casa mis papás
que otra vez me apoyaron y me prestaban
su casa y me dejaron hacer cocinero
ruido puro desastre pero ayer a mi super
oficina y empecé no conocía yo a nadie
de la moda en este en méxico y marcó que
me metía a myspace en ese momento no
existía instagram este a buscar las
fiestas que habían de moda y sin estar
invitados y está la lista nada me
aparecían de estas fiestas me vestía
súper cool como para que me dejaban
entrar y llegaba y le platicaba a quien
me pusiera enfrente de mi proyecto de mi
proyecto para mi agencia y tienes que
ver y tienes que ver y encontré fue
difícil encontrar como gente que
confiara en un escuincle que su oficina
era una azotea pero encontré una modelo
no mi primera modelo que firmé se llama
samantha zacarías que casualmente hoy
sigue siendo de mis mejores amigas y
arme un grupito de modelos y estaba yo
taloneando le y de repente apareció un
chavo que quería modelar pero resultó
que tenía como que más ideas como de
behind the shins y apareció este chavo
johan se asoció conmigo y juntos íbamos
subiendo no estábamos muy jóvenes me
acuerdo que no me toman en serio los
clientes cuando yo iba a verlos en
persona porque me veía muy chico tenía
23 años por hombre ella todo más chico
pues dejé de ir en persona había mucho
rechazo yo llegué a una industria en
méxico donde los
los grandes de la moda eran muchísimo
mayores que yo y no les interesaba en lo
más mínimo ni el cambio no tenían no
estaban abiertos a nuevas ideas y no
querían gente nueva no sabían mucho
rechazo de khedira juntas en persona
porque no me tomaban en serio porque me
queda muy chico en la ocasiã yo puras
llamadas y hacía voz como más del señor
cuando hablaba y hasta llegar a fingir
que un asistente entonces hablar es ya
es el asistente de david éste
y hacia lo que fue para que me tomara en
serio y me diera la oportunidad y
después de mucho sangre y sudor que
practicaba en una charla que tienes que
contratar que tenía mucha hambre y
encontramos esta charla que se llama
máster entró al equipo y se formó como
un triángulo perfecto y de repente
después de mucho trabajo empezaron a
llegar los éxitos este y mucho trabajo
pero empezaron a llegar no uno tras otro
y entre más éxito también más ataques no
sabes cuánta gente nos tiraba mala onda
nos atacaban los muchos chismes mucho
mucho odio no antes tuve que regresar un
poco eso a esa mentalidad de yo no voy a
dejar que la percepción de los demás
afecte cómo me veo yo y lo que yo sé que
yo valgo y lo que yo sé que yo tengo
pues me enfoqué en el proyecto y seguía
yo cambiándose y ha dicho enviando y
llegó todavía más éxito y aquí vino el
inverso de lo que les he dicho a empezó
a puro aplauso entonces todo el mundo te
dice es el más pregonero es lo máximo
eres ya sabes el dios de y me empecé a
creer como por dos segundos y luego me
di cuenta que es lo mismo sí también yo
dejo que su percepción de mi éxito
me engañe y cambie lo que yo pienso
entonces es igual de negativo entonces
yo dije yo me enfocaré porque cuando tú
te crees ese éxito así se te va yo seguí
enfocado en lo que en lo que yo quería
hacer y de repente ya teníamos modelos
mexicanas en milán en parís en toques en
los mejores desfiles del mundo las
mejores revistas y la ciudad de méxico
llena de modelos nuestras en el
escaparate eso se hablará mucho éxito y
muy muy bonito este y de repente
me pasa lo peor que me podría pasar
nunca me hubiera imaginado que me pasara
algo tan tan
fuerte
me empieza a cantar a todos mis trabajos
cancelan fashion week' que es muy
importante en la moda este los clientes
que nos deben dinero nos dejan de pagar
los clientes dejan de contratar se frena
en seco la industria pero en seco la
pandemia
y de repente no tengo nada que hacer o
sea todo está cerrado lo último que
alguien quiere en esa situación es
contratar una modelo o hacer un desfile
de modas no teníamos chamba para frenar
y ximo este yo me pasé los primeros dos
meses de la pandemia en casa de mis
papás la vez que estuvo increíble fue un
tiempo muy bonito con familia con mis
sobrinos que tengo miles con mis
hermanos yo soy el cuarto de cinco
hermanos todos super intensos en una
casa en donde si quieres que te escuchen
tienes que gritar porque todos hablamos
muy fuerte y fue un momento muy bonito
al principio de la pandemia pero después
de dos meses de estar todo el día viendo
películas y tragando y después de varios
kilos encima dije yo no puedo hacer esto
o sea me voy a empezar a deprimir pero
la industria sería frenada o sea
y yo no veía para cuando o sea estaba
muy muy fuerte la situación y de repente
una de mis mejores amigas
renata me habla y me dice voy a hacer un
puestito de raspados en san diego en
california en la playa ayudame entonces
super chambeador ayúdame a crecer mi
negocio y sin pensarla le dije voy para
allá para que mis maletas me fui a san
diego y la ayude con todo fue trabajo
más duro que ha hecho en mi vida en
términos de físicos ya era cargar el
carrito que pesaba horrible raspar el
hielo preparar los jarabes este empacar
todo llevarlo desmontarlo acomodarlo
atender clientes todo el día al rayo del
sol yo no soporto el sol odio el sol
creo que nunca me ha arrugado tanto como
esos tres meses que trabaje en este al
rayo del sol sudando como perro y
haciendo esto empezando a buscar ciertas
marcas de lujo para hacer posteos en
redes sociales y la vez que yo no estaba
el dinero entonces les decía que sí pero
me sentía súper hipócrita porque por un
lado yo estaba posteando esta vida
todavía de de glamour y de lujo y no era
lo que yo estaba viviendo yo no posteaba
lo que estaba haciendo que era vendiendo
raspados en la calle porque yo trabajo
en una industria en la que todo es
imagen y en ese momento mi agencia
estaba a punto de dejar de existir y yo
decía sí yo sí yo externo estoy si yo lo
público esa va a ser la gota que derramó
el vaso y se va hundir mi barco entonces
yo me si está súper hipócrita porque era
está todo el día trabajando y atendiendo
clientes y sudando y de repente mención
de un segundo y subía un post así that
no sé qué de palas de hierro hasta la
coque dos charlas llegaron una vez a
comprando raspados en dos ocasiones y me
dicen tú eres habido una vez el que hace
de skiles tu número es el que tengas una
marca que haces aquí vendiendo raspados
en la calle y no importaba repito que la
percepción de los demás no te puede
afectar porque si tú dejas que eso te
empiece a meter tías en la cabeza te
caes entonces yo tenía muy claro lo que
yo estaba haciendo y para mí era
sobrevivir y para mí todos los trabajos
son dignos y lo que yo quería era seguir
trabajando yo amo trabajar
fue un momento muy real en donde se
desapareció todo este glamour ya no
habían red carpets ya no habían desfile
ya no había nada de eso de ese mundo de
brillantina y tenía me quedaba lo real
que era la gente que más me quiere y la
gente que me quiere desde antes de que
yo sea alguien y yo me sentía tan feliz
que hasta me empecé a cuestionar quiero
que regrese me dé o sea quiero que las
cosas regresen quiero regresar al mundo
de la moda pero también si me jalaba y
lo extrañaba y fue un momento difícil o
cuestionando medio quién soy yo que va
que valgo yo sí todo lo que construir
toda mi vida fue esta carrera de moda y
ahora ya la perdí y ya no está y quién
sabe si va a regresar y fue un momento
muy bonito porque regresa a la raíz de
yo soy david no hoy por hoy el hombre
que ustedes ven aquí todo lo que soy se
lo debo a mis papás todo lo que sé de
arte de música de cultura todo me lo
enseñó mi papá todo lo que sé de
decoración de personalidad de todo lo
que soy soy un clon de mamá todo lo que
sé de trabajo de dinero
y empezar desde abajo todo me enseñó en
papá y gracias a eso yo soy quien soy y
hoy por hoy les digo que lo más
importante es no escuchen y no dejen que
las percepciones de los demás afecten
cómo se ven ustedes y afecten lo que
ustedes valen yo sé perfecto que tengo
un valor y eso no lo dejó de afectar y
no escucho a los demás ni cuando estoy
en la cima ni cuando estoy en el sol
gracias
[Aplausos]